why is it that we can know more about
the past but we can
influence the future in some way again
it's nowhere in newton's laws of motion
okay nor in any update of newton's laws
of motion
general relativity electromagnetism
schrodinger's equation in quantum
mechanics
all of these attempts at finding a
fundamental laws of physics
have the feature that they treat the
past present and future equally
now i'm not going to hold you in
suspense too much i actually know the
answer to this question
why is the past present and future so
different to us
the answer is something called entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics i'm
sure you've heard about this
before entropy is basically roughly not
exactly but close enough
the disorderliness of a system the
randomness the disorganization
and there is a law of nature that is
true in our macroscopic everyday world
that says that entropy increases over
time so a typical
example might be an egg you can have an
unbroken egg
it's easy enough to break the egg to
scramble the egg and in that process
from
unbroken to broken to scrambled the
entropy of the egg
increases you're mixing things up you're
making them more random
and that would just happen very easily
and naturally in the world whereas
if you saw a movie of scrambled eggs
reforming into an unbroken egg
you would know right away someone was
playing the movie
backwards in time there's a
directionality to the evolution
of these systems so the first law of
thermodynamics just says
energy is constant that's good the
second law
says that entropy increases over time in
a closed
isolated system or in the universe as a
whole you can clean up your room don't
get me wrong
you can lower the entropy in a localized
system by influencing it from the
outside world
but overall in the universe as a whole
entropy
increases over time so unlike newton's
laws or other attempts at fundamental
laws of physics
the second law of thermodynamics does
tell the difference between the past
present and future it says that entropy
will be higher in the future
it was lower in the past